things start to go sideways how do you
stay calm in the chaos our next guest
has the answers let's welcome to the
show mindset coast kristin royceland
welcome to the show hi thank you so much
for having me thanks for being here
you're not only now a mindset coach
you're a yoga instructor what else do
you do i do so many things i mean really
i'm just super passionate about
letting people feel calm connect with
themselves connect with their breath so
i'm a breath work facilitator
i'm also a mom of four hence the name
common total chaos because man it's
madness
okay so in the chaos how do we gain
control how do we get things back i mean
the biggest thing is to really be
present which is easier said than done
right i'm sure you hear that all the
time like get present just be present be
right here right now
so for me the best way to be present is
to connect with the breath
and
uh it's something that you have with you
all the time which i really love so
that's my number one go-to when i'm
feeling stressed out of my body
anxious overwhelmed all of those things
that we all experience especially in
this uh
coveted crazy time can you show us some
breathing techniques and you also have
yoga master we get down it's like a yoga
position i don't do yoga so i need your
guidance oh you don't okay so we are
gonna go on yoga mats yes you can do
these sitting standing as well but we're
going to sit just cross-legged okay i'm
actually going to sit on my shins just
to give a difference i won't make you do
that so you know why i'm growing like a
seven-year-old man here
the biggest thing when you sit on the
ground you also connect with
your the earth and yourself because now
you're not up you're not up and out
you're like okay i'm setting the
intention that i'm going to get calm so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to place two hands over our heart
okay and the reason we're doing this is
as soon as you place hands over your
heart you actually connect with your
nervous system and tell yourself you're
safe so you're right away going to feel
a little bit better do you feel it i do
i already feel relaxed yeah yeah so you
can comfort yourself and then you're
just going to close your eyes
and we're going to breathe in through
our nose all the way into the low belly
and then you're going to exhale it out
of your mouth
with some sound because the sound helps
release things so another big breath in
and a big breath out
good sound that sounds really great
another big inhale filling up feel
yourself grow taller and then exhale
side out let it go
just something as simple as that you do
feel a change you really do and it's so
easy too people to put thought into this
yeah that's that's it i mean that's
there's so many more but that is
something you can do throughout your day
before you come on a segment and when
you're driving in your car don't take
both hands on your heart you can take
those three deep breaths which is stop
and take those three breaths and that's
going to put you in a different mindset
yeah it totally shifts everything now
you have a journal here why do you have
a journal so
one of my other favorite things to do is
to get your thoughts out there's zen in
the pen so when you sit and you take
these three
it's true
so you take those three breaths you feel
a little more connected with yourself
and that's a really great time to ask
like how do i feel
what do i need and most of the time
we're not asking ourselves that we're
just kind of moving like what do i need
to do sure not how do i feel so i love
to ask myself that and then just sit and
write and i'll free write and just see
what comes up and sometimes it's really
surprising you're like oh i didn't know
i felt angry you're just kind of
free-flowing you're just writing things
out just whatever comes to my mind
you're putting a pen paper right there
pen to paper right there and i always
get really good insight and after i
finish same thing i'm in a different
i've let it out it's not in my body
anymore it's not taking up space in my
head it's gone we can go on for an hour
here i gotta wrap it up what's the best
way someone's watching right now i know
we have a podcast as well what's the
best way to get in touch with you so you
can listen to my podcast it comes out
every week it's called balanced chaos
and it's on spotify apple all the things
and you can find me on instagram